yes it does require voter id
the american people want that
and i say gently to my
democratic friends from texas
if if you don't if you don't see
the need for that then
there are one or two circumstances here
either you either you're so
dumb you lose your place during sex or
you want to cheat
when i lose my place during sex i just
refresh the browser window
[Applause]
[Music]
i was just kidding okay so while crime
spreads like a virus on a plane full of
democrats
at least we know true justice is being
done a florida man has been sentenced to
eight months in jail for breaching the
senate chamber on january 6th
carrying a trump flag the only surprise
he didn't get
life without parole now we're not
liberals so we get it you do the crime
you do the time we got that from beretta
for anybody
watching who's younger than 75 ready
he had a parrot no doesn't ring a bell
but you can still
question the penalty and you know if he
were blm
he would be a-okay but it's obviously
the obvious that they overdid the
sentencing
in fact they even admit it as one
assistant u.s attorney said
it will send a loud and clear message so
there won't be a next time
but you gotta worry when you become a
message because then you're screwed
it's a threat like finding a horse's
head in your bed or a book signed by
andrew cuomo
sensing should only be for the crime
and not for a greater message especially
a message
so manufactured you heard it yourself
the breach was the worst thing since the
hindenburg
the jfk assassination and synchronized
swimming all rolled into one
i believe that january 6 was in effect
a second kind of civil war the worst
attack on our democracy
since the civil war the worst attack on
our democracy since the civil war
the most serious threat to our democracy
since the civil war the worst assault on
the capital since the civil war
january 6 was worse than 9 11 because
it's continued
to rip our country apart the assault on
free and fair elections
is just such a threat literally we're
facing the most significant test
of our democracy since the civil war wow
it's like they're all working from the
same script talk about sending a message
and man they are on message the media
the democrats and even the judges but
why send a message about this
and not other things that are killing
people and i'm not talking about climate
change or misgendering your friend danny
hundreds of people arrested in riots
last year have all had their charges
dismissed and
these include people who threw
projectiles at cops and burned private
property
assaulted civilians and of course there
was the looting and the destruction of
businesses
in minneapolis alone you have over a
half billion dollars in damages
1500 properties damaged 150 buildings
set on fire
countless police injured maybe it's hard
to prosecute
mobs and masks but imagine if the
government had devoted the time and
resources
to punish these thugs with the same
intensity
they devoted to hunting down trespassing
grannies
who didn't wear masks stores could be
open again in minority neighborhoods
parked cars wouldn't get air conditioned
by broken windows
we could get ms-13 down to ms-5 or six
but they didn't instead they egged on
the civilians
to knock on each other they turned
america into a nation of mafia rats
because they hate anything that smells
of trump and so ignoring the helpless
cries of citizens
our government created an artificial
danger to keep us divided
that america is now at the mercy of a
white supremacist movement
not a crime wave that's paralyzing
cities across the country
yet we know which one is real and which
one isn't even the judge who sentenced
the capitol hill guy
used the same exact words from the media
judge randolph moss told the guy
although you were only
one member of a larger mob you actively
participated in a larger event that
threatened the capital and democracy
itself
now you could say that about the crime
wave but they won't but that sentiment
about january 6
had already been put into play over and
over by the media
that this day threatened democracy of
course the capital reopened
and our dear leaders were back to
pretending to work within hours
meanwhile countless businesses will
never come back since the crime wave
began
there are the dead who paid the price
for the cowardice of liberal leaders
remember david dorn you should because
the media won't
but good for you judge you got some
misguided nutter tossed into the clink
you saved democracy not really you just
parroted the media's message
which is who cares about criminal gangs
we got the dumb white protester covered
here are some san francisco locals
describing what it's like to run a
business
now overrun by looters they are
literally just taking it from the store
they're taking it grabbing it and
running the bottom window
is now boarded up because someone broke
into our store one night
a guy come and just grab anything that
he can get they casually come in
grab what they need and walk out i ran
up to stop them and they uh
they kind of threatened everyone here
and then they took what they wanted to
and left this has been going on for
a year and a half now it's really bad
really bad but i bet they're all really
relieved they
sentenced the guy from january 6th since
all of those thieves
must have been flaky trump supporters
but aoc will tell you those criminals
are only stealing bread to feed their
families
as they funnel the goods through an
elaborate fencing network
making millions for syndicates man has
she gone quiet on that
so the government has made a choice it's
not based on justice but fear
terrified of the elite activist class
they decided to let the mob steal
while locking up crackpots and funny
hats the guy didn't hurt anyone or
damaged property
what's he going to tell a cell mate that
he's in for loitering
so he's a he's political collateral
damage a trump supporter what the media
sees as sub-human
no recipient of mercy the security of a
country is now less important
than sheer political revenge they want
you crushed like the wheels on brian
stelter's desk chair
damn i know sorry i wonder what the
angry white male has to say
[Music]
sure is great taking a walk and being at
peace with my thoughts
you know it's so strange that those same
politicians who pushed for lockdowns
and then encouraged those violent
protests that led to the destruction of
cities
now want to decriminalize shoplifting
and property crimes
which will just further hurt america's
small businesses
i mean i just can't think of any reason
for it at all
don't say great reset it'll make you
seem crazy don't say great reset it'll
make you seem crazy
did i just say something
he is crazy but i wonder what the angry
black male has to say
[Music]
what it is what it was what it shall be
this is tyrus
enough said
you gotta be kid
what yes
what happened january 6 everyone
involved
that was arrested and was seen on video
is being
given some stiff sentences as they
should
it was a bad thing i don't believe in
what about ism
and i'm not taking one from the other
but i will say this everyone that
broke into a building burned down a
building stole
a bottle of water up to hundreds of
thousands of dollars in damages to
stores and buildings should also be
given
the same stiff penalties just putting
out there fair is fair
law is the law leave politics out of it
that's it
[Music]
so one last quiz what is a true threat
to democracy
citizens breaching the capital maybe or
a government enlisting private companies
to curb your freedom of speech while
turning your neighbors and relatives
into a bunch of squealers
or how about that same government
pretending a crime wave
is merely a distraction from unseen and
unnamed white terrorists
i think you already know that answer the
problem is does it matter
hello welcome tonight's guest
she's done more interviews than a hiring
manager at wendy's
fox business correspondent susan lee
he's our number one source for names
starting with jay
retired u.s marine corps bomb technician
and foxy
johnny joey joe three j's
cheerleader lawyer pundit
she's worn more hats than fans at the
kentucky derby
outnumbered co-host emily capano
and his animal tattoos are my massive
sidekick and host of the santa box
nation
iris
susan welcome to the show always a
pleasure to see oh good to see you
you're up to early in the morning so i
don't see you then what you know uh
this you you're at fox business what
kind of message
is it when no one gets arrested or
charged for looting
well we're kind of used to double
standards in washington remember when
that story broke that nancy pelosi is
worth 150 million dollars
and that's because she's been buying
stock her husband has been buying stock
that has been affected by policy that
she makes
but now if that happened on wall street
people would be
thrown away be put in jail probably for
the rest of their lives
for white corporate crime but in dc you
know it does it seems like a double
standard for others right members of
congress you can go in and buy stock
whenever you feel like
right right so you have a double
standard here then in which uh
you know obviously january 6 these
people go to jail but
a slow rolling crime wave you could get
away with anything you could go in and
shoplift
right well you know my grandpa used to
own a convenience store
so he was running away from civil war
and that was how he made his new life
here
in the new land and when i was little i
didn't know it at the time but he was
actually
he was being robbed right i was a little
kid i didn't know what was happening he
told me to go back into the kitchen and
i remember that stay there you were
there yes yes yes
so my grandpa was here trying to make a
new life right he's trying to build a
business and when
things are stolen he loses money it
hurts him in the end exactly because the
individuals are just trying to make a
living
that gets hurt by shoplifting and crime
then they leave they close up the
businesses they leave and those
businesses aren't there and then
the towns or the uh the the communities
slowly die
emily they slowly die you actually you
know we're a cheerleader for the raiders
so you're used to defending criminals
um
[Laughter]
except for the raiders
[Laughter]
so anyway um you are you are a lawyer
and you are what
why do you think there's this double
standard
i don't know but it kills me too just as
a human i feel like you don't even have
to be an attorney to see the injustice
here
and i think what's hard for me to
swallow as well as a criminal defense
attorney
is the fact that the prosecutors are
failing to do their job the system
exists
in a certain way uh so that it protects
both sides so that yes the defendants
are protected but so are the victims
there are advocates and representatives
of representatives of everyone in the
system uh in the court but here what
we're seeing is the complete erosion of
that duty on the prosecutorial
side so you talk about the slow dying i
mean we watched before our eyes
portland burned to the ground
essentially over a hundred straight days
of riots
and looting and fires and of all of the
federal
crimes that were referred for
prosecutions the d.a
dropped half of them and of those half
none went to trial and instead the ones
that got any type of sentence
it was literally doing community service
or quote encouraging people to vote
those were for crimes like assaulting a
federal officer right burning down the
federal building to the tune of three
million dollars but
you know earlier you mentioned revenge
in your intro and in those riots i will
never forget one of those writers sign
said
we don't want biden we want revenge
right exactly
what's up j-cubed how are you
happy birthday
[Music]
i turned uh i turned old enough to run
for president today
excellent yeah but i'm not gonna do it
unless tammy duckworth does
oh that way no one can say i used my
legs to win
and she doesn't get to okay oh
okay i have to do this every time
likes joking around you can laugh
that was not a joke that was not a joke
no one here thought it was funny that he
crossed his leg and then uncrossed it
and inside relief
no one saw that i thought it was funny
sorry just putting it out there joe
i'm gonna i'm gonna throw out a
conspiracy theory that i came up with
so it's probably true how is it possible
that all the protests and riots suddenly
just went away and nothing was solved
well you know what i mean well we got it
it was almost like it was like a faucet
that was turned on
and then turned off i mean coronavirus
there's a lot of things that that get
exacerbated and go away
and then maybe come back when it's
politically advantageous here's a really
good
the war in afghanistan uh we didn't
fight a 20-year war we fought 10
two-year wars because we had
midterms presidential elections right
but just on this topic
point you know you said earlier you're
like hey
how why does this double standard exist
well it's
obvious why it exists it's in political
intimidation that's exactly what it is
you cannot you cannot create an argument
to me
that that white dome uh
just i can't remember the lego model the
capitol building monolith
i had a mausoleum to corruption ah damn
that's a i would have gotten
yeah yeah yeah so
you cannot tell me that in that that is
more of a symbol of democracy than every
town square
across the country amen and that's what
bothers me so much but here's the
difference the people that exist in
those quiet town squares are just
the people that go about their lives
they are rule followers so they're easy
to punish
but when people aren't real followers
they're not easy to punish and that's
the problem the problem is
that this the message was clear you can
come for them but don't come for us
don't come to capitol hill go to small
towns we don't care about that but don't
come for us don't come for the ruling
class
that really pisses me off the way you
frame it yeah i mean it's true
which is real as it gets yeah just
pisses the hell out of me
because i know i know that uh jj
triple j is right i don't know what i'm
saying tyrosine you know what you said
it uh
you said i made a really good point uh
as the angry black male
that consistency is what matters yes but
we're in the midst of a con
and it's piggybacking what he's saying
here's the thing we're playing the same
game we've just changed the rules
now you have people coming out and
unfortunately most of the time they're
people of color who have been elected
by masses of different colors saying
that things are as bad
as they ever wore you can't prove it we
can't deny and if we challenge it
we're part of the problem so then you
can go ahead
and influence people who just want
something to burn down
and you're not concerned with what the
reactions of it is and the more that
they do it the more things you can say
and then at some point when the jig is
up and you've got enough money
because everyone who's speaking about
the injustice of this country
is making a lot of money on speaker fees
and donations to the cause
and the millions and eventually to be
trillions to make all this money to
solve a riddle
that they already know the answer to
they're just taking the playbook from
the time when things were really bad
when it was jim crow error when there
was a huge difference when
if a brother walked in the store and he
stole a piece of bread to feed his
family
he'd get 20 years no parole now
if a one-on-one white person does it
walks into the thing does the same thing
he would have got a well he needed food
he needed it for his family
so i supprect him for having the courage
to go in there and take what's his for
his family
we've just changed the roles now now
it's white america that's the problem
because they didn't want
equality they want opportunity and
advantage when you have opportunity
advantage
you can profit from it and as long as it
doesn't happen in their yard
where everyone gets crazy sentences you
can they can eat themselves
and then you can profit from it and
that's what we're seeing in this country
we just we have just switched roles
flipped the script and and white people
unfortunately
have been conditioned not to fight back
and you guys need to fight back and i
just end with this
i'm so sorry that your grandfather left
the civil war
came all the way to america lo and
behold to find out it's worse than a
civil war yes
so sorry such a good point
yeah that's the woke thing yeah where
are you at the worst thing since the
worst day he got here
this is worse than when i left damn it
sorry
i'm sorry that you guys had to deal with
it all right up next they said screw the
civilians while their private security
cost millions
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else